secretary Hagel secretary Mabus admirals
Grenier and Lara days Mayor Gray leaders
from across this city and armed forces
to all the outstanding first responders
and most of all the families whose
hearts have been broken we cannot begin
to comprehend your loss we know that no
words we offer today are equal to the
magnitude to the depths of that loss but
we come together as a grateful nation to
honor your loved ones to grieve with you
and to offer as best we can some solace
and some comfort on the night that we
lost Martin Luther King jr. to a
gunman's bullet Robert Kennedy stood
before a stunned and angry crowd in
Indianapolis and he broke the terrible
news and in the anguish of that moment
he turned to the words of a ancient
Greek poet Aeschylus even in our sleep
pain which we cannot forget falls drop
by drop upon the heart until in our own
despair against our will comes wisdom
through the awful grace of God
pain which cannot forget drop by drop
upon the heart the tragedy and the pain
that brings us here today is
extraordinary it is unique the lives
that were taken from us were unique the
memories their loved ones carry are
unique and they will carry them and
endure long after the news cameras are
gone but part of what wears on as well
as the sense that this has happened
before part of what we're what wears on
us what troubles us so deeply as we
gather here today is how this senseless
violence that took place in the Navy
Yard echoes other recent tragedies as
president I have now grieved with five
American communities ripped apart by
mass violence Fort Hood to son Aurora
Sandy Hook and now the Washington Navy
Yard and these mass shootings occur
against a backdrop of daily tragedies as
an epidemic of gun violence tears apart
communities across America from the
streets of Chicago to neighborhoods not
far from here and so once again we
remember our fellow Americans who were
just going about their day doing their
jobs doing what they loved in this case
the unheralded work that keeps our
country strong and our Navy the finest
fleet in the world these Patriots doing
their work that they were so proud of
and have now been taken away from us by
unspeakable violence once more we come
together to mourn the lives of beauty
and to comfort the wonderful families
who cherish them once more we pay
tribute to all who rush towards the
danger who risk their lives so others
might live and who are in our prayers
today including officer scott williams
once more our hearts are broken once
more we ask why once more we seek
strength and wisdom through God's grace
you and your families this Navy family
are still in the early hour of your
grief and I'm here today to say that
there is nothing routine about this
tragedy there's nothing routine about
your loss your loved ones will not be
forgotten it will endure in the hearts
of the American people in the hearts of
the Navy that they help to keep strong
in the hearts of their co-workers and
their friends and their neighbors I want
them to know how she lived Jessica
Guardi said of her mother Kathy she is
not a number or some statistic
none of these 12 fellow Americans are
statistics today I want every American
to see how these men and women lived may
have never met them but you know them
they're your neighbors like Arthur
Daniels out there on the weekend
polishing his white crown victoria and
Kenneth Proctor with his beloved yellow
Mustang who if you asked would fix your
car too she was the friendly face at the
store sylvia frasier with her
unforgettable gold hair who took a
second job at Walmart because she said
she does loved working with people she
was the die-hard fan you said next to it
the game Kathy Gaarde loved her hockey
and her caps season ticket holder for 25
years there were the volunteers who made
your community better Frank Kohler
giving dictionaries to every
third-grader in his County Marty boo
drug leading the children's bible study
at church they lived the American dream
like Issa intended who left everything
he knew in India for this land of
opportunity and raised a wonderful
family and dedicated himself to the
United States Navy they were proud
veterans like Gerald Reed who wore the
army uniform for more than 25 years and
Michael Arnold who became one of the
Navy's leading architects of whom a
colleague said nobody knew those ships
like him they were dedicated fathers
like Mike rigel coaching his daughter's
softball teams joining Facebook just to
keep up with his girls one of whom said
he was always the cool day
they were loving mothers like Mary
Frances night devoted to her daughters
and would just recently watched what
Joy's or older daughter got married they
were doting grandparents like John
Johnson always smiling giving bear hugs
to 10 grandchildren and who would have
welcomed his 11th grandchild this fall
these are not statistics they are the
lives that have been taken from us this
is how far a single act of violence can
rip them a husband has lost his wife
wives have lost their husbands sons and
daughters have lost their moms and their
dads little children have lost their
grandparents hundreds in our communities
have lost a neighbor and thousands here
have lost a friend as has been mentioned
for one family the Daniels family bold
wounds are ripped open again pasillas
lost Arthur her husband of 30 years only
a few years ago is Mayor Gray indicated
another shooting took the life of their
son just 14 years old I can't believe
this is happening again Priscilla says
but these families have been endured a
shattering tragedy it ought to be a
shock to all of us as a nation and as a
people it ought to obsess us it ought to
lead to some sort of transformation
that's what happened in other countries
when they experienced similar tragedies
in the United Kingdom and Australia when
just a single mass shooting occurred in
those countries they understood that
there was nothing ordinary about this
kind of carnage they endured great
heartbreak but they also mobilized and
they changed and mass shootings became a
great rarity and yet here in the United
States after the round of clock coverage
on cable news after the heartbreaking
interviews with families after all the
speeches and all the pundit tree and all
the commentary nothing happens alongside
the anguish of these American families
alongside the accumulated outrage so
many of us feel sometimes I I fear
there's a creeping resignation that
these tragedies are just somehow the way
it is that this is somehow the new
normal
we can't accept this as Americans bound
in grief and love we we must insist ear
today there is nothing normal about
innocent men and women being gunned down
where they work there's nothing normal
about our children being gunned down in
their classrooms there's nothing normal
about children dying in our streets from
stray bullets no other advanced nation
endures this kind of violence none here
in America the murder rate is three
times what it is in other developed
nations the murder rate with guns is ten
times what it is in other developed
nations and there's nothing inevitable
about it it comes about because of
decisions we make or fail to make and it
falls upon us to make it different
sometimes it takes an unexpected voice
to break through to help remind us what
we know to be true and we heard one of
those voices last week dr. Janis
Orlowski steam at medstar washington
hospital center treated the wounded and
in the midst of one of her briefings she
spoke with heartbreaking honesty as
somebody who sees daily and nightly the
awful carnage of so much violence we are
a great country she said but there's
something wrong all these shootings all
these victims she said this is not
America it is a challenge to all of us
she said and we have to work together to
get rid of this
and that's the wisdom we should be taken
away from this tragedy and so many
others not accepting these shootings as
inevitable but asking what can we do to
prevent them from happening again and
again and again I've said before we
cannot stop every act of senseless
violence we cannot know every evil that
lurks in troubled minds but if we can
prevent even one tragedy like this save
even one life spare other families what
these families are going through surely
we've got an obligation to try it's true
that each of the tragedy as I mentioned
is different and in this case it's clear
we need to do a better job of securing
our military facilities deciding who
gets access to them and as
commander-in-chief I've ordered a review
of procedures up and down the chain and
I know that secretary Hagel is moving
aggressively on that as a society it's
clear we've got to do a better job of
ensuring that those who need mental
health care actually get it and that in
those efforts we don't stigmatize those
who need help those things are clear and
we've got to move to address them
but we Americans are not inherently more
violent people than folks in other
countries we're not inherently more
prone to mental health problems the main
difference that sets our nation apart
what MIT makes us so susceptible to so
many mass shootings is that we don't do
enough we don't take the basic
common-sense actions to keep guns out of
the hands of criminals and dangerous
people what's different in America's is
easy to get your hands on a gun and a
lot of us know this but the politics are
difficult as we saw again this spring
and that's sometimes where the
resignation comes from the sense that
our politics are frozen and that nothing
will change what I cannot accept that I
do not accept that we cannot find a
common-sense way to preserve our
traditions including our basic Second
Amendment freedoms and the rights of
law-abiding gun owners while at the same
time reducing the gun violence that
unleashes so much mayhem on a regular
basis and it may not happen tomorrow and
it may not happen next week may not
happen next month but it will happen
because it's the change that we need and
it's a change overwhelmingly supported
by the majority of Americans
by now though it should be clear that
the change we need will not come from
Washington even when tragedy strikes
Washington change will come the only way
it ever has come and that's from the
American people so the question now is
not whether as Americans we care in
moments of tragedy clearly we care our
hearts are broken again and we care so
deeply about these families but the
question is do we care enough do we care
enough to keep standing up for the
country that we know is possible even if
it's hard and even if it's politically
uncomfortable do we care enough to
sustain the passion and the pressure to
make our communities safer and our
country safer do we care enough to do
everything we can to spare other
families the pain that is felt here
today our tears are not enough our words
and our prayers are not enough
if we really want to honor these 12 men
and women we really want to be a country
where we can go to work and go to school
and walk our streets free from senseless
violence without so many lives being
stolen by a bullet from a gun then we're
going to have to change we're going to
have to change
on Monday morning these 12 men and women
woke up like they did every day they
left home and they headed off to work
and jerrell Reed's wife Kathy said see
you tonight for dinner and John Johnson
looked at his wife Judy and said what he
always said whenever they parted goodbye
beautiful i love you so much
even in our sleep pain which cannot
forget falls drop by drop upon the heart
until in our own despair against our
will comes wisdom through the awful
grace of God what Robert Kennedy
understood what dr. King understood what
all our great leaders have always
understood is that wisdom does not come
from tragedy alone or from some sense of
resignation in the fal ability of man
wisdom comes through the recognition
that tragedies such as this are not
inevitable and that we possess the
ability to act and to change and to
spare others the pain that drops upon
our hearts so in our grief let us seek
that grace let us find that wisdom and
in doing so let us truly honor these 12
American patriots may God hold close the
souls taken from us and grant them
eternal peace may comfort and watch over
these families and may God grant us the
strength and wisdom to keep safe our
United States of America
you